mesdames et messieurs bonsoir les
incendies de forêt font rage dans le
midi cilly accalmie dans le gard et dans
le vaucluse les pompiers des sauveteurs
mobilisés dans le var et sur la côte
d'azur ont vécu une nuit
particulièrement épuisante
car ils ont dû tenter de réduire une
cinquantaine de foyers d'un incendie
sinon davantage la région où le feu est
le plus violent c'est le massif des
maures et les flammes des passants
grimaud et la garde freinet ont
progressé en direction de saint-tropez
le préfet du var monsieur manière à
déclencher le plan de sauvetage orsec
c'est à dire celui que l'on applique
lorsqu'il ya danger grave le préfet a
lancé également un appel à tous les
plaisanciers qui sont dans le midi ne
gênez surtout pas le ravitaillement des
avions canadair qui viennent se
ravitailler sur les plans d'eau ils ont
priorité absolue il est du devoir de
tous chacun dans la mesure de ses moyens
d'aider les sauveteurs réduit à
draguignan le pc de lutte contre le feu
a sollicité des renforts en divers
endroits et 50 de sapeurs pompiers de
paris avec 10 véhicules de secours sont
partis par les premiers trains ce matin
prêter main forte à leurs collègues du
midi qui sont sur la brèche depuis de
très longues heures quittant le fort de
brégançon où il séjourne pour quelques
jours de vacances
monsieur giscard d'estaing s'est rendu
sur les lieux où les incendies font rage
80 foyers s'étaient déclarés hier dans
la zone rouge comprise entre l'hérault
et le var plus la corse et bien
aujourd'hui ça continue le feu a pris
cet après-midi en 11 points différents
dans l'hérault de nombreuses évacuations
étaient décidées notamment celle d'un
grand hôtel le panorama entre sète et
mèze
mais c'est encore dans le var où le
président de la république s'est rendu
cet après-midi en hélicoptère que porte
ce soir l'effort principal des docteurs
2000 hommes ils sont engagés avec l'aide
des canadairs qui ont été concentrés ici
et on y attend le renfort des pompiers
de paris
le mistral continue de souffler avec
force avec des rafales de 80 km heure
ont sport tantôt loin des flammèches qui
allument de nouveaux foyers
les images filmées cet après midi mais
montre ce paysage de désolation
il nous devient habituel hélas chaque
été pour une bonne part des foyers
l'origine criminelle ne fait pas de
doute même s'il est vrai qu en août avec
la sécheresse et la chaleur les pinèdes
prennent feu aussi facilement que de
l'amadou l'imprudence en tout cas la
négligence le mépris souvent de
l'environnement sont des causes
constante de ses véritables catastrophes
écologiques dont les conséquences sont
incalculables
le midi n'est pas la seule région de
france où il ya des ferait notre pays en
compte un peu partout qui vont de la
merveilleuse forêt des chaînes de
tronçais au sapin de la ligne bleue des
vosges et surtout milliers et milliers
d'hectares de pins dans les landes
or fort heureusement très rares sont des
incendies en région landaise pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'il s'agit là
principalement de vastes exploitations
privées dans les propriétaires font très
attention puisque les pinsons des arbres
de rapports alors que dans le midi il
s'agit le plus souvent de broussailles
qui n'appartiennent à personne
la forêt des landes de gascogne couvre
un million d'hectares d'un seul tenant
450000 en gironde 580000 dans les landes
et environ 40000 dans le lot et garonne
elle constitue le plus grand massif de
bois de cultures d'europe
son rôle économique est très important
pour la région en 1977 par exemple la
consommation en moins d'industrie s'est
élevé à 2 millions de mètres cubes
consommation destinés à la fabrication
de la pâte à papier et de panneaux de
particules au cours de cette même année
la consommation de bois d'oeuvre a été
de 2 millions 300 mille mètres cubes le
bois d'oeuvre est utilisé en
construction pour les parcs et les
lambris les moulures le sillage la
menuiserie cette utilisation représente
les trois quarts du chiffre d'affaires
en outre compte tenu de la crise de
l'énergie
on note une certaine reprise du bois de
chauffage et des projets sont à l'étude
quant à l'emploi énergétique du bois la
forêt en aquitaine emploie actuellement
de 35 à 40 mille personnes toutefois
cette richesse naturelle est fragile
dans la mesure où son premier - sipa
l'ennemi et le fus la surveillance à vue
est aujourd'hui encore la plus efficace
la forêt a donc été découpée en 23
secteur comprenant chacun un pylône
observatoire et de telle sorte que d'un
poste de guet à l'autre l'observation
puissent se regrouper
celle ci est assurée par des pompiers
professionnels connaissant parfaitement
leur secteur franck qui s'étend sur un
rayon d'environ 10 km chaque guetteur
est en liaison constante par radio avec
le pc opérationnel situé à sale et les
gens pensent que le pompier le patro
dans le cadre de l'intervention sur le
feu de forêt c'est une erreur en fait
nous sommes considérés comme des
conseillers techniques du maire c'est le
maire de la commune sinistrée qui est le
responsable des secours
y voici en alerte qui prime le
déroulement des opérations sur son
pylône le guetteur observe une fumée
dans l'origine lui est inconnu il en
effectue aussitôt le relevé qu'il
communique immédiatement au pc
indra 217 pour l'air dose parler chaque
observateur ayant un indicatif et
l'écoutent radio est en permanente les
deux observatoires les plus proches du
lieu d' alerte font à leur tour un
relevé de la fumée et transmettre leur
enseignement au pc nous l'avons vu tout
à l'heure l'implantation défensive est
telle que le moindre départ d' incendies
se trouve obligatoirement entre trois
centres de défense dont le plus éloignés
se trouvent a dit l'officier de
permanence porte sur la carte les
données transmises par les guetteurs et
dont le point de croisement localise
avec une erreur de 50 à 200 m le lieu
exact de la fumée en question il aura
fallu quarante secondes pour le décrire
en direction de jordi parler l'ordre de
départ est alors donnée à une unité dans
les trois centres les plus proches
une unité est constituée d'une voiture
légère radio et de deux gmc porteur
d'eau de 2500 à 3000 litres en fonction
du type ce matériel on le sait date de
la dernière guerre certes il a été
modernisé mais actuellement compte tenu
de son rapport coût efficacité
aucun autre véhicule tout terrain ne
peuvent supplanter en gironde aussi bien
dans les dunes de sable que dans les
marais où les sous bois touffus et en
broussaille et les points jeu naturel
permanent au nombre de 300 étant
insuffisant il a fallu pour améliorer le
système construire une trentaine de
châteaux d'eau d'une réserve de 30
mètres
à ces réserves situées près les
agglomérations sont venus s'ajouter
récemment des citernes construites à
même le sol en pleine forêt il y en a
aujourd'hui une centaine d'une capacité
de 60 mètres cubes tel est le dispositif
du corps des sapeurs pompiers forestiers
qui a implanté un centre de défense au
pied de chaque observatoire notre
station fr3 de marseille nous envoie un
extrait de la déclaration faite par
monsieur giscard d'estaing après s'être
rendu sur les lieux des incendies de
forêts dans le mythe
là aussi je voulais surtout rendre
hommage à tous ceux qui luttent jour et
nuit pour s'efforcer de contenir et de
limiter cette catastrophe qui frappe le
département du var est également
d'ailleurs à côté le département des
bouches du rhône pendant que beaucoup de
français sont en vacances et notamment
dans cette région plusieurs centaines
d'hommes
à l'heure actuelle 900 dans le
département du var qui appartiennent
pour moitié aux forces de la protection
civile et des sapeurs-pompiers pour
moitié aux forces militaires lutte pour
contenir le sinistre est pour le refoulé
ils ont marqué des résultats importants
néanmoins comme vous le savez les
conditions météorologiques sont
difficiles avec un vent très fort et
surtout un vent changeant et à l'heure
actuelle tous les moyens sont rassemblés
pour circonscrire et je l'espère pour
réduire ensuite ce sinistre je voulais
au nom de la population du département
et de tous ceux qui s'y trouvent rendre
hommage au courage et au dévouement de
ceux qui jour et nuit combattent pour
limiter les effets de ce sinistre
monsieur président beaucoup d'élus
locaux ont demandé pour les années à
venir un renforcement en matériel
français c'est une hypothèse envisagée
et il ya plusieurs problèmes il ya
d'abord un premier problème qui est un
problème de prévention parce que il est
certain que nous ne pouvons pas avoir
tous les ans à répétition des foyers qui
s'allument dans l'ensemble des forêts de
la région de provence côte d'azur il ya
donc un problème de prévention à la fois
sur les causes et je demanderai à mes
yeux les départements messieurs les
préfets des départements de
rendre compte au ministre de l'intérieur
à la fin de la saison 2 des observations
nous aurons pu faire sur les causes de
ces sinistres de façon à ce qu'ils ya
d'abord un effort de prévention pour
éliminer ces causes ou pour aménager le
massif forestier pour tenter d'éviter la
propagation du feu vous avez néanmoins
que ceci est naturellement en fonction
des conditions météorologiques et que
par exemple un vent comme celui d'hier
est telle que même lorsqu'il ya des pare
feux dans les forêts celles ci sont
franchies et l'étoile heureusement le
feu continue à se propager il ensuite
les moyens matériels
il est certain que nous devons disposer
des moyens matériels suffisants pour
permettre la protection de la forêt
provençale une seule information au
chapitre de la politique intérieure
aujourd'hui l'opposition s'interroge sur
une riposte commune à la politique
économique du gouvernement dans une
déclaration et ce paul quilès membre du
secrétariat national du parti socialiste
souhaite et je ne cite que face aux
mesures économiques et sociales du
gouvernement mesures représentant
l'attaqué la plus violente que l'on ait
connu depuis longtemps en france contre
les salariés
l'union de la gauche s'affirme à nouveau
le parti socialiste répond ce faisant à
monsieur georges marchais qui souhaitait
récemment l'unité d'action pour
mobiliser les travailler tempête autour
du paquebot france qui a été racheté il
ya quelques semaines par un armateur
norvégien son acquéreur précédent le
milliardaire saoudien akram ojjeh le
france quitterait pour toujours le
arbres ce mercredi 15 ou sans que l'on y
est effectué de réparation
hier la cgt avaient organisé des
manifestations pour protester contre les
décisions du nouveau propriétaire
l'armateur norvégien kloster en fait en
juin 80 lefranc la bêtise et nord ouest
qui signifie norvège en anglais
reprendra du service comme mabire de
croisière pour cela il devra subir
d'importantes modifications afin d'être
en mesure d'embarquer plus de passagers
et de consommer moins de masi or c'est
un chantier à demain à brême qui a
enlevé le contrat pour ces travaux de
transformation qui sont d'un montant
total de 150 millions de francs
les allemands sont moins cher et plus
rapide que les français c'est ce
qu'affirme l'armateur norvégien en tout
cas qui offrirait en contrepartie de
commander ou chanter du havre deux
paquebots de croisière la sphère ce pôle
it is
les réactions sont nombreuses notamment
monsieur robert leroy député communiste
de la seine maritime écrit dans une
lettre adressée
mais ministre que si la formation je
veux dire le départ prochain se confirme
je cite une telle décision serait une
nouvelle preuve délibérée du
gouvernement de mener la politique du
déclin de la france
bref le paquebot qui portait ce nom de
france n'a pas fini de faire parler de
la coupe de france le trophée du
football a été comme vous le savez
emprunter avant-hier dans les locaux du
football club de nantes par des
sidérurgistes de longwy et syndicalistes
de la cfdt l'objet d'art a été présenté
aujourd'hui à l'heure du marché sur la
place principale de longwy les habitants
dans l'ensemble ont approuvé l'action
menée par des emprunteurs du trophée
celui ci va reprendre la route de nantes
et retrouver ainsi sa place habituelle
dans les locaux du football-club
l'initiative des sidérurgistes de longwy
ne doit pas dit ceci être considérée
comme un acte de banditisme ou de
chantage
mais comme une action pour populariser
la lutte engagée pour protester contre
les mesures de restructuration des
usines du nord de la lorraine mais
emprunteurs avait d'abord demandé qu'un
match de football nantes
détenteur de la coupe contre strasbourg
champion de france fut organisée à
longwy même au profit du fonds de
solidarité des travailleurs en lutte
dans le bassin lorrain le calendrier du
football ne semble pas rendre les choses
faciles et monsieur fontaine ou
président du football club de nantes a
proposé de son côté une surtaxe spécial
sur les billets vendus à l'occasion
d'une journée de championnat de france
pour alimenter le fonds de solidarité
aux dernières nouvelles les responsables
de l'opération emprunt maintiendraient
leur demande d'un match nantes face book
étrangers le cardinal américains wright
est mort hier à 70 ans
c'était le préfet de la congrégation
romaine du clergé sa mort laisse une
place vacante dans ce que l'on appelle
le gouvernement de l'église le cardinal
wright était par ailleurs l'un des trois
membres de la commission chargée par feu
le pape paul vi de se prononcer sur la
révision de monseigneur le faire au
nicaragua l'épiscopat a demandé à la
junte qui a pris le pouvoir il ya quinze
jours après l'écrasement du dictateur
commence à une généreuse amnistie en
iran sinovel exécution dont d'ailleurs
trois bandits de grand chemin sera pop
427 le nombre de personnes passées par
les armes
depuis la création des tribunaux
révolutionnaires votre part by ap la
comédie est maintenant assurée d'une
très confortable
vérité au sein de la commission des
experts qui rédigeront la nouvelle
constitution de livre à 60 sièges sur 75
leur installation est retardé d'une
dizaine de jours en attendant
l'ayatollah procède à la réorganisation
des armées et à ce que nous appellerons
l'encadrement de la presse à rome
le gouvernement de monsieur que sig a
constitué après cette mode crise
ministérielle a obtenu la confiance la
chambre des députés
l'ue a voté cette confiance par 287 voix
contre 242 les socialistes se sont
abstenus
les communistes ont voté qu'au deux
enfants sont morts cette semaine en
italie victimes d'accidents du travail
il avait 12 et 13 ans ils sont morts en
travaillant à l'usiné cela se passe au
20e siècle et non pas dans l'angleterre
de charles dickens c'est que dans le sud
de l'italie pour combattre la misère
certains n'hésitent pas à faire
travailler des gosses avant même
l'adolescence et quelquefois des six ou
sept ans ils fournissent un certain
nombre d'employeurs sans scrupules de la
main d'oeuvre clandestine à bon marché
bernard benyamin et jean-françois renou
se sont rendus près de naples la petite
chérie où ils ont rencontré l'un de
saison il s'appelle salvatore cozzolino
il a 12 ans il a perdu sa main droite il
ya quelques mois dans un accident du
travail
on l'appelait tapo biando têtes blondes
aujourd'hui ses camarades l'ont surnommé
il peine sonate au littéralement le
retraité depuis que l'état a consenti à
lui verser une pension de 165000 lire
par mois environ 850 euros
nous avons voulu savoir combien d'élèves
travail et au dehors il y en a beaucoup
énormément même nous a simplement
répondu
l'instituteur et babine la zone ici est
très sous développés il y a une majorité
de familles ouvrières avec beaucoup
d'enfants à l'école fonctionne seulement
pendant quatre heures par jour à mille
temps alors quand les enfants sortent de
l'école ils sont contraints de rester
dans la rue pour jouer ou alors pas être
employée dans les bars ou les épiceries
et c'est contre la loi
bien sûr que c'est contre la loi mais
les parents et les employeurs respecte
la loi du silence et l état ne fait rien
en disant il n'y a pas de structures
publiques alors il est presque naturel
que les enfants et cette ville a du
reste comme vous le savez les
statistiques les chiffres officiels sur
l'enfance sont effrayants la mortalité
infantile à naples dans la première
année de vie et le 40 pour mille des
chiffres qui sont probablement
inférieure même dans le tiers-monde
ici nous sommes dans le quart monde
mais plus grave encore est le cas de ces
enfants que nous avons rencontrés au
hasard des rues de nappes qu'ils ont
entre 6 et 12 ans et ne vont même pas à
l'école ils ont déjà la responsabilité
de gagner leur vie et pour y parvenir
souqués bourse
oui
aujourd'hui comme tous les autres jours
il y a des pattes à la maison impossible
de faire autre chose à manger pour la
mère de salvatore à 47 ans elle a seize
enfants à nourrir
j'ai que le jour nous sommes venus chez
elle six enfants seulement se trouvait
là la seule ses occupations de cette
maman napolitaine c'est la nourriture
sa hantise ne pas avoir assez à manger à
la maison pour sa progéniture dans ces
conditions lorsqu un plat de pâtes et
sur la table les enfants n'ont d'autre
solution que de manger manger et encore
manger
il compte y gagna bape estime en écho au
succès de l'accidenté louisiane
ido collègues et les fidèles célèbrent
croit le sun youth ici les gens me
disent tu es seul de tony moore signora
kekoa faraday ce qu'on souffre il compte
ou tizi famille la famille halimi
deux jours avant sur le banc dire madame
est émise par moby john est louche
encore sur les persos pas ici pour vivre
on espère que ça résonne qui vit à moult
notre confrère le matin de paris publie
dans son supplément d'aujourd'hui un
long article de bernard langlois le pays
dont le prince est un cheval c'est le
haras du pin en juin d'argentan dans
l'orne en fait le charme de ce sport
devient de plus en plus à la mode où il
revient ces utilisations sont nombreuses
et il existe désormais des compétitions
officielles international d'attelage à 4
pour la première fois c'est la france
qui organise le championnat d'europe
coïncidence les dates de la compétition
sont à cheval fin août début septembre
douze pays vont venir et prendre part au
pain donc sur les terres entre en irak
lundi dernier l'équipe d'antenne 2 avec
daniel bilalian vous a présenté en
détail
conduire un attelage à quatre c'est
difficile pour les gens du xxème siècle
qui vivent dans général dans les vapeurs
d'essence et le grondement des
automobiles et bien justement le sport
de l'attelage permet de retrouver des
gestes de jadis de remonter le temps et
d'échapper aux pollutions
parmi les concurrents a annoncé un grand
personnage le président de la fédération
équestre internationale
le patron des sports équestres dans le
monde le mari de la reine d'angleterre
le prince philip qui a reçu en
exclusivité antenne 2 au cours de son
entraînement en angleterre
ce matin-là il pleut et les chevaux sont
l'objet de soins attentifs on va jusqu'à
leur permirent les sabots un peu pour
que la boue ne s'accroche pas un peu par
tradition d'élégance le prince philippe
at elle toujours lui même casquette
trench coat style gentleman fermé il
plus disait jamais la pluie fait partie
des richesses d'éternel de l'angleterre
dans le pays du thé l'eau a même quelque
chose de respectable pour le prince
comme pour ses chevaux il s'agit
aujourd'hui surtout d'un entraînement de
maniabilité le championnat au pain dans
quinze jours comprendra d'autres
épreuves encore notamment d'endurance
mais l'essentiel est de ne pas forcer
des chevaux tout en sentant au bout
bérelles qu'ils sont déjà en condition
physique
nous sommes à windsor devant le
formidable château construit par edouard
iii
il y a 6 ans en premier exercice il
s'agit de faire faire à l'attelage une
sorte de slalom entre les plots jaunes
et voyez avec quelle placidité ces
animaux obéissent à ce que philippe leur
demande de père sans rien perdre de leur
camp pas soit c'est que depuis azincourt
les chevaux anglais qui vont en france
se doivent de garder un certain
sentiment de
période et mais oui les valets de pied
sont anglais eux aussi la preuve après
les plots jaunes un gay profond l'homme
doit rassurer d'attelage mais comment le
prince est il sélectionner ses chevaux
pour le championnat d'europe et bien
parmi les serviteurs attitré et habituel
de l'état le même coup leur grandeur
mais pour nous ils sont tous les chevaux
qui font le travail de l'état de
l'oeuvre il parle d'un disque de tous
alors il doit être assez grand pau
porter le grand autre comme le grand art
mais grand oui est ce que vous allez
prendre part comme concurrent dans le
championnat d'europe je voudrais bien
mais
le mois de septembre on a lancé trois
voire quatre qui sont prêts pour ça vous
ne savez donc pas si vous serez
sélectionné non présents ici débarrasser
des airs mais chaque matin ces chevaux
pendant des semaines viennent
s'entraîner oubliant les chevauchées
officiel et leur carrosse des
processions d'apparat l'image symbolique
du siècle au dessus de la tamise
paisible l'avion à réaction qui
d'ailleurs ne gêne nullement ses chevaux
habitué aux cliquetis des paroles
montons près de notre hôte
les chevaux comprennent deal ce que vous
voulez
face aux combinaisons de voix de
m
des circonstances
le faut être nous faire un peu de tout
mais le vois plutôt parce qu'ils
composent et comment comprenez vous vous
ceux qui le veulent et ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas en droit d'être en tête s'y
colle
on va faire une analyse de chaque cheval
tout le temps un peu l'autre pensait qu
est ce qu il pense qu'est ce qu'il pense
et à quelque chose à qu'il n'aime pas et
celui là il veut tourner ici le fonds
doit analyser les pensées de tout et
chaque phrase tout le temps aux toutes
dernières nouvelles le prince philippe
malgré ses doutes vient mais oui d'être
sélectionné dans l'équipe britannique
il sera donc au pain sa double qualité
de président de la fédération équestre
et de concurrents mais s'ils gagnent
l'attelage à quatre
comment va-t-il faire pour se remettre
la coupe à lui même il va falloir qu'il
se coupe en quatre
nous accordons une large place aux
compétitions de l'art du pain dès à
présent à rendez-vous les divers édition
de nos journaux télévisés l'image de
septembre et nous y reviendrons aussi
plus tard le tiercé se dispute à nouveau
à deauville les preuves retenues et le
prêt du journal de dix marches ex prix
de la municipalité 2000 mètres pour
chevaux de 4 ans et au dessus ils sont
nombreux et ils sont bons ils sont bons
donc pire et brad pitt
il n'y aura que 19 partants dans le prix
de la municipalité de nos vies mais le
lot est composé de chevaux de qualité
mme à laquelle la voie que vous voyez
ici ne sera pas le grand favori de cette
épreuve pourtant il faudrait il pourrait
fort bien créer une surprise c'est mal à
kahnawake à la mer en super forme
les chances des mots ce faire elle
s'habitue bien deauville qu'est ce qu'il
a fait comme travail me plaît beaucoup
je la vois comme ça a l'air vraiment
belle et un coup d'état
quels sont les chevaux qui pourrait
venir l'inquiéter j'étais intérêt ça
s'entretient
personnellement je placerais malaquais
la ouate en quatrième position dans la
sélection quand je crains la distance un
peu trop longue pour lui c'est roya
pinacle qui sera la base de mon tiercé
via ne restait sur une deuxième place à
longchamp je le vois une première chance
thalys fille du ski en réalité le fils
de centre cuche est un poulain qui a une
qualité classique et je pense vraiment
qu'il devrait terminer
sinon premier au moins deuxième parce
que le terrain sera lourd et c'était 1
qui préfèrent demain à deauville vous
soumettons sur le presque string drifter
a fait de progrès considérables et
robert collet son entraîneur pense qu'il
devrait pouvoir gagner cette épreuve
malak al hawa cela veut dire le roi du
vent en arabe
je mets donc en 4e position dauphin du
roi déjà fait ses preuves à deauville où
il a gagné plusieurs courses gran mogol
un peu couru cette année il a été
préparé spécialement pour ce meeting de
deauville et handicap comme celui ci
devrait lui convenir
ensuite tout river qui vient de finir
troisième d'un tiercé sur sa forme
actuelle
il devrait pouvoir récidiver halderman
qui porte ici un poids favorable
56 kg terminera la sélection et je vous
rappelle les numéros qu'ils porteront le
dise le 4 le 17 le 12 le 1 le 3 le 13 et
le 7 le temps pour demain dimanche sur
les régions méditerranéennes temps se
payer mistral et tramontane faiblissent
ans légèrement par mieux d'ailleurs à
cause des incendies de forêt sur les
autres régions ciel nuageux à très
nuageux avec éclaircies l'après-midi
principalement du sud de la bretagne
l'aquitaine en revanche du nord de la
bretagne aux frontières du nord du reste
du centre est quelques pluies
intermittentes sont prévues températures
toujours basse cour d'assises avant
présence et bernard pradines au qui vous
présentera les dernières informations
vous le retrouverez j'en suis sûr demain
dans 1 tonne de 12h à 20h demain soir
nous retrouverons si vous le voulez bien
mais je ne vous dirai pas ce soir
simplement bonsoir merci
en effet voici de belles images pour
terminer le journal
dans samedi et demie présenté par joseph
chopin vous avez pu assister à une
grande première
en effet à l'occasion de la dernière
journée des épreuves du championnat du
monde de vol libre qui se déroulait à
saint-hilaire du touvet dans l'isère un
reporter cameraman de la cp didier
levrat avait pris place à côté d'un
pilote du deltaplane une étonnante
performance que vous avez pu revoir sous
une autre forme d'ailleurs cet après
midi en direct toujours sur les écrans
dans penda par conséquent regardez bonne
soirée
merci
les vapes
voilà il arrive par anti sida sida il
dégage très joli joli la mort ouais
ouais c'est magnifique ça m'inquiète
balle est bon théo
alors
j'ai plus tôt
c'est plutôt de l'autre côté on y va à
terry wey
putois repoussoir
douchka
y'a pas le trapèze